Hello,
I'm Zina puddle.
Welcome to the concert hall in Stockholm
where the Nobel prize winners received
their awards from the king of Sweden for
their outstanding contributions to
science,
literature and Economics.
This is the first time that this year's
laureates or repairing together on
television and they've been joined by
their family and friends who've traveled
to Stockholm to share in the
celebrations.
And we are also joined by students from
here in Sweden who are going to be
putting their questions to our laureates
on this year's Nobel mine.
So we have discoveries on repairing
damaged DNA,
which increase our knowledge of the
universe,
cure tropical diseases.
And in economics we throw light on the
links between poverty consumption and
welfare.
And the literature prize gives voice to
the voiceless in authoritarians
societies.
Laureates,
congratulations to you all.
[inaudible]
wonderful.
Let's go straight away to our first
question from our audience here.
And it is Martin.
Martin please.
Your first question to our laureates.
So there are a lot of the prices and
competitions in all of your fields and I
just wanted to have your opinion,
do you think it is a good addition to
motivate people to get engaged or do you
think it inspires unnecessary
competition?
So well I kind of miss or never
competitive.
We have something called perfect
competition which economists believe in.
Um,
I'm not sure the Nobel does much of
that.
I've been very impressed by how much
positive um,
just general happiness and wellbeing it
seems to generate.
Um,
it's clear though over the years in the
past there certainly is some resentment
on behalf of people who don't win.
I've never felt that personally.
But you hear discussions stairs when you
pass by.
I have not experienced any of that.
I'd been very fortunate that way.
But I do think in the past people have
felt that a whole area,
you know,
that should have been recognized,
never was recognized,
for instance.
And I'm sure,
and that's a more legitimate feeling
them.
I'm sure there's some people who feel
that they should have been writing guys.
They're more not,
you are a professor date.
And in saying that,
but I'm sure you deserved your price,
but let me just see what,
uh,
anybody else poor madre to professor
moderate.
Yeah.
Well I think it's useful and bringing
visibility to science fields.
Um,
I uh,
agree with Angus.
I think that there have been instances
where people have felt certainly in my
field that the certain areas that were
worthy of a prize were neglected.
And,
and uh,
so there is a value judgment I think in,
in,
in selection of the fields.
Professor Campbell,
I think a,
it does not create competition among
sign,
just don't compete for that.
And secondly,
I think it's inevitable and it also adds
a nice little bit of,
um,
something special,
uh,
the time just kinda enjoy.
So I think it's sort of inspirational
and not confrontational and certainly
not inducing and not the juice of,
of competition.
And the chemistry failed our way.
Been very fortunate and that the three
winners worked on different mechanisms
of DNA repair and we had no competition.
So we've been fortunate to have it that
way.
And so in this particular case,
there was no competition.
It rounded off the chemist there.
Professor Thomas Lindahl okay.
Yes.
I think a healthy competition is a good
thing.
Yeah.
Uh,
it's uh,
excellent different scientist goes a
little bit of a stray with his idea,
send that sample Dale's correct them and
uh,
I think it would be too comfortable if
there was no competition at all.
Huh.
Okay.
So you met us on Alec Serve,
which obviously you are the literature
laureate,
I should say.
Actually,
of course,
everybody that a spirit line,
Alex overage is speaking in Russian.
Um,
and I know the question was specifically
about science,
but in terms of receiving the Nobel
prize,
as Professor Deaton said,
it's a very,
it's a real accolade.
I mean,
do you feel that it's going to help you
in some way,
do what you do better?
Uh Huh.
Yeah.
Just cause [inaudible] [inaudible] no.
[inaudible] [inaudible] no,
they deal with sweat.
Delish murals.
Trixie [inaudible] premiums in a love
with the deal
[inaudible]
the physicist professor aren't
Mcdonald's and then,
oh,
you want to go first?
Professor Cogito.
Yes.
Okay.
Whoa.
We both wanted to understand what is
[inaudible] properties of neutrinos and
we have the same gold and coming from
different experiments and we are very
much
complimentary rather than competitive
complimentary rather than competition.
So I'm getting the sense of that to
Martin,
your question about it.
Um,
perhaps encouraging competition is,
uh,
not getting much traction here,
aren't Macdonald.
Yep.
I think the scientists are primarily
motivated by the science.
They're attempting to understand our
universe more completely.
I think they're quite satisfied when
they recognize themselves that they have
made a breakthrough and have understood
things more completely.
I think when there is the recognition
like this by such a respected body as
the,
uh,
people who define the Nobel prize,
it's something that is highly respected
in the community.
It adds to the joy of having made a
significant discovery.
So nobody really,
does anybody resonate briefly on what
professor Deaton said about some sad
damage,
tormented souls going around saying,
Oh,
I should have won the Nobel.
I could have won the Nobel.
It's not fair.
Has anybody come across any of such
individuals?
Yeah,
I have a comment when you mom more then
why I should that none.
Uh,
Juan didn't know about when you see a
major breakthrough in your field.
Yeah,
I personally feel very bad.
I should admit that discover not that
I'm doing right now.
There is something called Crispr is very
hot in our field and I wish I would bet
that just color myself,
I would give anything for it.
So,
um,
it's,
it's not competition per se,
but it is a US scientists and
individuals drive to,
to discover an important thing.
Thank you for your honesty professor
Joe.
All right.
So now we were moving to a specific
question,
which is for you,
Professor Angus Deaton,
your of course economics laureates,
and you won your prize for really,
I'm shedding a great deal of light on
the links between poverty consumption
and welfare and what implications there
are for policy makers,
um,
particularly in setting levels of
taxation from instance.
But let's see what comes up from our
students.
Andrea with
hi,
I have a short question.
Is Fighting inequality a realistic aim?
MMM hmm.
It's maybe a short question though.
I'm not sure if short answer,
I mean here I think is the essence of
the matter,
which has,
we have tools to fight inequality.
You know,
you could have in United States are much
more
progressive tax system presidents.
You know,
we could spend more money on education
unless I'm on the fence.
I've heard as he's talked about that.
Um,
and there's lots of things you could do.
so the question is not having the tools.
So it's realistic in the sense that we
have the tools,
right?
It's unrealistic in the sense that the
politics is extraordinarily difficult.
So you know,
the people who have all the money,
all it's got to have a lot of political
power and they're not very interested in
fighting inequality.
And so what do you do if you think
there's too much in equality or
inequality is reached dangerous levels,
which I do.
Then I think the best thing to do is,
is you have to participate in the
democratic process and persuade other
people that it's a problem.
For instance,
by being on a TV show like that.
So it is can be done,
you see?
But it's a lack of political will.
The tools are the,
you mentioned taxation sort of in
passing,
but just briefly outline for us then,
what are the tools that can be used to
reduce inequality?
Well,
this,
a lot of tax tools.
I mean,
one of them for instances like an
inheritance tax for example.
But many of us have always thought that,
um,
you know,
fairly stiff inheritance taxes were a
good thing because it helps,
it stops you having this hereditary
inequality.
What Thomas picketty famously is called
patrimonial capitalism,
please.
The French economist has written a lot
about inequality.
That's right.
And I think many of us think it's good
for each generation,
each group of kids who are born each
generation to have an equal chance,
not just depending on what their parents
have and two ways of doing that.
One is um,
you know,
um,
and Harrison's taxes.
Another is trying to equalize the
opportunities at schools and there's a
big concern in the United States now
that um,
you know,
the best schools are going to the kids,
um,
off the well off people and it's very
hard,
much harder than it was in our
generation for kids,
for poor families to get into,
to get a really first class education.
And that's absolutely vital
professor as he said.
Joe,
would you mind mind bringing you in just
on this particular point?
Yeah,
because I hope you don't mind saying
that you were born in Turkey.
That's right.
One of eight children.
Right.
And your parents could not read or
write,
write and here you are a Nobel laureate,
completely exemplifying what professor
did
do.
United State has 25% of total prisoner
population and that has to do with
quality.
It has to do with lack of opportunity.
And that is a problem.
I think there was a recent article in
New England Journal Medicine comparing
the health care system and in Turkey and
the United States,
it's much better in Turkey,
Turkey not have the resource,
the United States.
And here we,
we pass the [inaudible] or Obama care,
which is a universal healthcare system
and we're still fighting it,
a growth in the United States still
fighting it.
So,
um,
even though I come from a country where
the resources and,
and uh,
and so on are not as it does as the
United States,
I think in,
in a certain aspect,
in terms of equal opportunity for
education,
education and Tokyo is free,
you don't have that,
but it was just your,
your own individual personal story
illustrates that.
If you're given that equality of
opportunity,
somebody of your,
of background can rise to top can do it.
And I wish my adopted country would take
the necessary steps to do that.
All right.
Okay.
Thank you.
There was another question for you,
professor Deaton and that's from David
Gandolfi.
David.
Uh,
thank you professor [inaudible] for
coming here and think 12 the Nobel
laureates.
My question is specifically you have
expressed some criticism about foreign
aid to poor countries.
Now why is that?
Okay.
Um,
so let me start by saying that I'm not
critical a tall of the wish to help
people in poor countries,
but I think a lot of what we're doing in
terms of foreign aid right now is
actually not helping a tall and there's
lots of things we can do from the
outside which will make the new
innovations,
the new discoveries and so on,
which will help poor countries.
I think countries that have very large
aid and flows into the domestic economy
that tends to undermine the sort of
responsible government,
um,
that you need in order for development
to have any chance of taking place.
I think that sort of aid,
I think a bill here is my example of
exactly the sort of aid that really
works,
um,
which is we can spend money in the
United States and Sweden and so on to
get the sort of discoveries that save
millions of lives or save Fifo for being
brought blind.
Um,
that's a sort of aid.
So I'm not a blanket against aid,
but if we can help spend money,
I mean,
Merck made that drug available through
the World Bank that too many people
around the world.
And you know that that's a huge gift
from rich countries to poor countries,
don't you rulers in Africa because you
can't trust them for what they'll do
with it.
Or we're creating dodgy rulers by,
you know,
basically saying,
you don't have to raise anything from
your own population.
We'll keep you in business by giving you
a norms of sums of money.
So,
you know,
we're making the dodgy rulers even
dodgier and that's the one of the
central problem.
He's opened up a whole can of worms
there.
I know you like worms.
We're going to come to that later.
Now,
Viet China,
alex serve it.
We come to you,
you,
I'm off from Belarus C or better
Russian.
And you won the Literature Prize for,
uh,
your whole body of work that you've
written over many,
many decades giving voice to the
voiceless you've wished and things like
voices of Chernobyl about the gasoline
nuclear accident in 1986 of you brisson
and Zinky boys about this Soviet Afghan
war when though we're young Russian
soldiers coming back in zinc coffins,
hint,
hence Zinky boys talked about,
um,
women's suffering and in the Second
World War.
And,
and that has led to a genre that you
describe as a documentary novel.
And the citation said that you have the
soul of a historian and in many ways you
write,
um,
your,
your work.
So based on the testimony of,
of,
of real people.
So that's just by way of background of,
of your,
your work.
But let's see what the question is for
you.
And I think that,
um,
Diana,
you have a question diner.
Yeah.
If Vietnam.
Uh,
so do you believe your message gets out
there in a better way by using a
journalistic methods rather than a
fictional ones?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] proportion the
story to [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] cock coach,
totem priests who did them.
But you have also like a journalist's,
been a very political and very outspoken
in your criticisms,
both of President Lukashenko of a better
Belarus and a your half Ukrainian.
So you've also been very critical of
President Putin and his actions in
Ukraine,
particularly over crime mirror and so
on.
So I think a lot of people are very
interested in what you have to say about
the current political situation that is
going on in the former Soviet Union.
And I wonder if you would just briefly
give us an idea of how you see things
evolving in that part of the world.
Was it the chiller Roscoe call tootie.
Tootie.
Uh,
per poet.
[inaudible] Piatt at the class,
each square forma pushkin that year.
Now the support as Dallas.
But they're,
uh,
Missouri Mills River to Illinois
steeping of [inaudible] you
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] a risk of a dis
little scope besides what year some are
possible social [inaudible] e
[inaudible] at this understand that you
named seriousness of what a,
no.
Uh,
so really new research and the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] a preschool
teacher and teacher.
Not Myopic.
Alinea took the deal.
A pity story.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] what's the
chance?
Could have seen me at create a really
study [inaudible] is this,
we meet them.
We'll see.
Bearish.
Tell me.
[inaudible] uh,
dessert pass number of circumstances.
She immediate,
uh,
what other cousin was session the
attack,
but are most,
um,
so we're doing is there as a VC
[inaudible] school boomer in a Bentley
illiquidity show?
No,
we will medalia machine swoboda earth,
which is [inaudible] you at a Napoleon
yet.
And there was no [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
thank you.
We have another question for his fee at
Leonard from Jamie.
Right now,
the work is a face with a huge
challenges.
Sasha
claim change ongoing conflicts on the
waves of refugees who are fleeing the
countries.
With this in mind,
what makes you optimistic about the
future of mankind?
Humanity.
So Soviet zone,
Alec Soviets.
That's a question for you briefly if
you'd be so kind as to answer that
question because I have to say you have
been described as a writer of
catastrophes.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] the Dudley
diligently worksheet and it weakened the
stuff that she's now is through
[inaudible] [inaudible]
thank you very much indeed.
Uh,
Svetlana.
Thank you.
So,
um,
I think now we moved to a specific
question for the professor William
Campbell,
one of the three medicine and
physiology,
a laureate,
but to your two colleagues are not with
us,
you,
you two from China who was awarded the
prize for discovering a very effective
malaria treatment,
artemisinin derived from natural plants.
And interestingly enough,
she actually went and referred to a
Chinese book on h on medicine,
Chinese medicine,
which is 1,700
years old.
Um,
but you were also awarded the prize
Professor Campbell with professor a
murderer from Japan.
Um,
and he sent you some soil when he sent
the institute that you're working at
some soil samples.
And from that do you manage to derive,
um,
treatment for terrible tropical diseases
elephantiasis where the limbs really
swell and river blindness,
which is a terrible affliction that um,
ha has ruined lives millions of lives.
So that's what you won the prize for.
But let's hear what the question is from
Jeremy.
Jeremy Falls Forsberg.
Thank you
professor Campo.
Where do you think that the next
generation of antibiotics will come
from?
Are they coming primarily from the
nature itself?
Yes,
I think they are most likely to come
from nature.
And I think we have a approach this
evenly in the past.
We sometimes get caught up with very
sophisticated modern technology and its
possibilities of finding new drugs.
It's odd and reassuring to me that all
three of us involved in this particular
prize,
um,
worked with plants,
or products of nature.
And I recently made a proposal Arcane
back to what I've been making for over
40 years.
But my proposal now is to have a much
greater scouring of the world for novel
microorganisms or animals or plants that
may provide the next leads.
And there are talents out there that I
think could it be brought to bear.
Um,
you know,
if,
if countries can put men outside of the
earth and bring them back to Earth,
uh,
one would think they could solve some of
these problems.
But when you were working on,
try on what led to Ivermectin and you
talked about how you went to Togo in
Africa when it was really uplifting for
you to see the children being treated
from this terrible illness,
which their parents and grandparents,
you know,
literally rendered blind.
Uh,
was that a motivating factor for you,
this sort of compassion?
Was that part of the,
uh,
the motivation for they get beard was
inspirational to me.
It was uplifting for me.
It was a fabulous thing for me,
but most researchers,
even in medical fields and setting aside
certain idealistic physicians,
but most researchers and medical field
are interested in the research and they
are interested in doing research that
might turn out to be good,
but there is their motivation is
basically the curiosity,
the scientific challenge.
Um,
certainly was saw that it'd be great if
this was useful,
but uh,
which is not done for reasons of
compassion.
And I think that's a frequent
misunderstanding.
But also by way of perspective,
let me say this,
that's when I was employed by the Merck
pharmaceutical company many years ago.
I was employed specifically and solely
to try and find a new drug for
schistosomiasis,
a tropical disease,
sometimes called snail fever.
And that spelled hot sandwich build
hardship.
I bill her ties.
It was,
and I worked on that,
solely focused on that for seven years I
had an unblemished record of failure and
I had a wonderful time doing it.
I was not the slightest bit discouraged.
I intended to spend with the rest of my
life doing it.
But I got into a lot of other things.
And that project was carried on by other
people in my department for many,
many years.
I was never asked you to stop doing it.
I never ceased to be funded for doing
it.
And I think there are lots of discussion
we should have about
that.
Anybody pick up a,
although despite this breakthrough of
treating these terrible diseases,
compassion was not necessarily the
motivating factor.
Yeah.
Professor [inaudible]
we work on cancer research so people
also call the time,
are you finding any new drugs for
counselors are trained,
can we cure cancer?
And uh,
I hope that will be an important
consequence of what we are doing.
But as I see it,
it's still the side effect of what we
are doing.
What we are really trying to do is
understand the world we are living in
how cells function.
Once we know that we can develop new
drugs and all kinds of other nights
I have follow up.
Yeah.
I have not been this jealous of Nobel
prize in medicine my entire life.
I rarely buy why an I heard it.
I said this is the way to give no value
for somebody.
Yeah.
I had a lab meeting that morning and we
usually discuss our experiments and I
just didn't discuss the experiment.
I discussed Nobel and Madison and I this
cost heroes and these guys are my,
yeah,
absolutely.
What they did.
I can I say their professors,
San Joe,
somebody who's an expert in DNA and
maybe jeans and that kind of thing.
You might try and isolate the mvg and
use yourself and then a forward tree
twice about everybody now.
So well that I just didn't see the,
the chemists Nobel laureates have come
in here.
Chemistry Nobel.
No,
it's,
let's go to our specific question on
your,
your work on repairing damaged DNA.
Emma Erickson,
you have a question.
Do you think that the future is strategy
of the,
um,
curing cancer will be to repair the
reparation systems of DNA or,
uh,
will the changes in behavior be more
important?
So should people change their behavior?
Poor,
moderate,
yeah.
Certain behaviors are directly caused
cancer.
Smoking as one,
um,
alcohol?
Well that I'm not going to that
my personal,
my personal kalea man who enjoys a tip.
Hello?
I drink out.
[inaudible] my personal belief is that
the alcohol,
alcohol itself is not known to the a
carcinogen,
but one of its metabolic products is,
and,
and I think it's quite clear that
certain,
it's probable in my view that certain
food products may have a cancer causing,
could you say some food products because
they're happy not to have headlines.
I mean there have been any of them been
addressed in there,
popular media and,
and I think the evidence is incomplete
and uh,
but I think the evidence will be
forthcoming and,
and this,
I think we'll probably go a long way to
reducing or potentially reducing the
incidence of cancer in the human
population.
Oh,
so you think the evidence will come
because we have about the British
breakfast,
the English breakfast.
Right.
You know,
15 years ago it was debatable whether
smokers,
you'll say 50 years ago
it's debatable whether I,
oh,
cigarettes cause cancer and,
and it's quite clear.
No,
I mean it's completely unequivocal and
yeah,
not alcohol though.
Sometimes you eat cured,
processed meats are cooked.
You too.
Well,
if he's good enough for you,
professor moderate.
Well,
yeah,
it was,
I say not as I did a professor has he
Sandra,
cause your particular work focused very
much on um,
some exposure to sun and Uva damage
ultra violet down yet he was still,
some babies don't mean that spine off
there are
vigorous.
I'm like k itself and why men being a
carcinogen,
there is no doubt that uh,
uh,
sun exposure ultraviolet cause just came
cancer and uh,
yeah,
um,
uh,
people do some bait and uh,
um,
how you change people's behavior.
I don't know how to do it.
We'll move onto our physics.
Uh,
Laurie,
it's now to cocky Kavita and author
Mcdonald's because you won your prize
for neutrinos telling us that neutrinos
which are this subatomic particle which
is ubiquitous in our universe,
used to be thought that it had no mass.
You've discovered that it does have some
mass and I understand that there are
billions of these things passing through
our body and so on and so forth.
And um,
in some way it will help us understand
how the universe works better.
But anyway,
that's a very brief summary of your,
um,
what you won the prize for.
But let's get our question from
Elizabeth Elisabet.
Lily blood your question please,
to the physics laureates.
Do you think that mankind will benefit
in the future from researchers in fields
beyond applied physics such as Astro
particle physics in more ways than by
increasing our general knowledge of the
universe?
Hmm.
Professor Macdonald,
the greater degree to which you can
understand the details of the laws of
physics to better you are to apply such
thing.
I'll give you an example,
even from the such esoteric and
difficult to detect particles as
neutrinos,
neutrinos are outside the general
experience of,
uh,
of humans.
Maybe once in your lifetime and the
trainer will stop in your body and
change one at home and do something else
and you won't even notice it.
But that's really the only influence
that you have.
And,
and yet there are something like 6
billion neutrinos going through your
fingernail per second from the sun.
Well,
we use those neutrinos from the sun to
understand the uh,
fusion processes that are taking place
that power the sun with great accuracy.
In fact,
the puzzle that we solved a,
that neutrinos do change from one type
to another,
which implies they have mass.
I was able to sort out what could have
been a problem with the calculations of
how many neutrinos are produced and
therefore the understanding of the
basic,
uh,
fusion power of the sun confined by
gravity.
It's now been determined that these
calculations are accurate,
too much better than 10%.
Those are the same types of calculations
that are being applied and to try to
harness fusion power here on earth
confined by magnetic fields.
And so it's a prime example of how
knowing the pure physics as accurately
as you can,
enables you then to apply those laws of
physics and trying to move forward with
applied physics.
Hmm.
Professor Casita.
I mean it's interesting that Professor
Arch Mcdonald there talks about how I
think it's one of the three types of
neutrinos is,
is from the sun.
And mentioning this idea,
a few nuclear fusion is what I want you
to ask you about because it often people
are looking at that now as a source of
energy for us.
I mean that's,
it is this,
is this something which your discovery
that neutrinos have mass could perhaps
help us harness nuclear fusion from,
from the sun better?
Let me mention the application of pure
physics into the,
the uh,
applied science wanting another example.
Not neutrino physics.
Okay,
well this a year is the a 100 years of
general later activity.
People thought this is really a pure
science,
no application to daily life.
However,
after wine 100 years,
we cannot leave without the knowledge
of,
to narrow their activity because gps is
based on Tim,
you know,
later activity.
No,
we use GPS.
But if we have no idea but [inaudible]
activity,
the GPS doesn't work.
So didn't know Lira tvt which was
thought to be pure theoretical,
pure basic science.
Is it two hours a day?
He died after 100 yet?
So maybe new t knows.
Could it also be great fun?
You know,
I'm just going to bring in a grantee
Nordstrom,
I think you've got a question which is
very related to the answer you've just
already given.
Professor Guy Cogito.
Um,
I'm wondering if you think that focus
off academia should be on fundamental
research,
so to find out how the world really
works or if we should focus more on
application and product development.
Who'd like to pick pick up on that?
And then professor calculators already
kind of addressed that.
Yeah,
I've done that too.
I think history is clearly shown us time
after time.
The of the power of knowledge and
knowledge comes from basic science or,
or,
okay.
Basic research and other fields and,
and uh,
I mean it's hard to develop new things
if you do not understand how the world
works.
And that's really the goal of basic
science and I think that's,
it's an intrinsic value.
I would argue that every major metro
modern medical advance is directly tied
to advances in basic science.
Hmm.
Yes,
we Atlanta Elixir richer.
I want you to ask you,
because obviously you're not a
scientists,
but your writing is very much based on
knowledge.
And research which you get from the
people you talk to,
who bear witness to the upheavals in the
events that you have drawn on for your
writing.
So,
um,
really is picking up the professor.
Modric she's point that,
um,
you need to anchor what you do on
research in your case.
Talking to people.
Yeah.
I just cause I [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] totally.
Kaltura.
Totally mean tiredness.
Totally web [inaudible] twist a chiller
vehicles.
Chill.
Avia.
Yeah.
You do.
[inaudible] proud of
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] no.
[inaudible] [inaudible] probably will
give us thank you professor eating.
You won't just give me,
I just wanted to come back a little bit
to compassion and curiosity and you
know,
fun.
So I,
we all do this.
I mean,
everything I've heard about,
you know,
when you're actually doing the work,
you're motivated by curiosity,
by trying to resolve puzzles,
by trying to resolve paradoxes and saw.
I also remember as he is at a previous
meeting saying that one of the greatest
moments in his life is when he's in the
laboratory and he sees something and he
thinks only God and I for the moment
understand those processes.
And I,
I mean in my way I can think of things
like that too.
There's a moment when I suddenly
understand something and everything fits
into place and you know,
I just know a whole bunch,
you know those lights suddenly where
there was darkness and missed before and
that's a wonderful feeling.
But so we don't do it for compassion.
We do it for that feeling,
that Aha moment,
that discovery.
But you know,
it's all within a social context in
which that are funding agencies.
I there their society who's deciding
which fields are really important to
work on.
There's people responding and economics
whenever those like,
you know,
in the Great Depression.
That was what caused some of the
greatest future Nobel laureates and
other people to move into economics
because they wanted to help people.
So it was the compassion,
the drove people into economics.
It's funding agencies,
it's poverty.
In the world.
And for me it's always been,
that's for me it's been very direct,
lovely makeup client.
Uh,
I uh,
as a scientist I usually think that what
I say no,
and I'll start scientists pay any
attention to and I'm really gratified
and very happy that Dr Dayton,
uh,
as coach me twice.
Absolutely.
But I should say that actually
interesting enough,
you as eastern jar or an MD,
a medical doctor as you are to um,
Thomas Lindahl but you only lasted one
year.
It was a doctor and you only two years.
It's a shelter.
Yes.
So you didn't have the compassion gene
to carry on health.
Professor Lindo weekly
like to go back to sweat Lana's comment
that we are in the privilege society,
we can pursue our ideas without being
regarded with suspicion by the
government.
I'm old enough to have had called digs
and down some somber kin,
eastern Germany,
uh,
a bit over 35 years ago and it was
Soviet stepped the local scientist,
they immediately became my friends too.
I never met them before because we had
the common enemy and there were people
in gray suits who are sitting in the
room trying to figure out if we were
doing something subversive in their mind
scientist for the same thing as
terrorists.
And uh,
that was an uneasy feeling.
Yeah.
And uh,
I think that has largely disappeared
now.
Okay.
So we've got some,
a couple of questions now if I can go to
Anneli Borg first and then Rabiah Aau.
But if you could both give us,
um,
your point,
Anna Lee.
Yes.
So my question is whether you would
encourage young person or a student to
become a scientist in your own field.
Okay,
thank you.
Ruppia.
You,
what skills do you think for most
important on your way to success?
Okay,
thank you.
Um,
who would like to pick up on Annalee
Borg?
Would you encourage a young person or
student to become a scientist in your
field?
Professing the,
I have to say it.
Let me ask you because I know that you
had a teacher,
a chemistry teacher who you didn't
really get on with and who failed you in
fact,
and yet here you are.
I can't mistreat laureate.
How about that?
Huh?
Clean stuff.
There are some teachers that are very
bad teacher.
You should be stubborn in science.
Uh,
you shouldn't be easily discouraged.
occasionally you meet scientists to have
some idea that's obviously wrong and
they just spend years and years pursuing
that idea.
But that's exception of the,
I think it's much more common that
scientists give up too easily.
I,
you have an unusual observation and
nature's telling you something here.
You are privileged,
you have new information and that you
shouldn't just put it in a drawer
because you don't understand it.
Professor Dayton,
you actually didn't start off.
They wanted to become an economist.
Did you?
You actually went into university to
study mathematics
and then gave up on it already gave up
on me.
Huh?
I would say one thing though,
and some of you are not going to like
this,
but you know,
the mathematics I learned early on has
been incredibly useful to me even though
I'm not a mathematician.
And there's a very wide range of
sciences and economics and other things
where mathematics is really important.
So,
you know,
push yourself as far as who cam,
um,
in that direction.
Um,
there's obviously areas where it's more
important than others,
but it's often extremely important and
it helps you think very clearly.
Um,
as part of it,
we're all talk about how this or that
teacher made a big difference now lives,
um,
because they're not paid well,
they're not respected in society are our
best minds do not go into teaching.
And I just hope that through this
medium,
uh,
both young scientist I young people and
their parents encourage their children,
the capable,
intelligent children to become teachers.
[inaudible].
And one
thing I'd like to say in and use you as
an example,
perhaps professor Bill Campbell,
is that don't be scared of the
contradictions perhaps within you,
because I know that you have a huge
love,
admiration and respect for parasites and
worms.
And yet ironically,
you've spent your life researching how
to kill them,
right?
So there's this,
I'm bivalence here,
but I know in your spec on you'd like to
paint them,
you paint worms.
And when you met President Barack Obama,
he gave you a stuffed animal in the form
of a word,
right?
Pride of place in your home.
Um,
and you also write poems about worms.
So I'm hoping that you might be able to,
uh,
give us a rendition
and my poems,
I sometimes like to speak on behalf of
the worms and gives them a chance to say
something.
And then I do happen to have one in
particular,
the case for a worm that causes river
blindness.
In fact,
um,
I can imagine it being very frustrated
and getting more and more angry as
people accuse it of causing blindness
when blind.
This in fact is a chance of shoot of
their infection there.
The causative agent does migrating
through the skin all over the body and
some of them are going to end up in the
eye.
And those humans,
of course,
we were very,
very unhappy about it.
But I imagine I'm one of those where I'm
saying this and you have to remember
that I think they're pretty frustrated.
I don't need your goddamned,
I,
all I need is a piece of skin big enough
to let me drop a few larvae in just
enough to make sure that they will be a
pickup and delivery.
Don't look at me that way.
I don't need your God damn high.
[inaudible]
Bill Campbell at that actually thank you
to all of our lawyers especially,
but both [inaudible] and renewed.
Congratulations to all of you.
Thank you to our students who have given
us questions,
some encouraging,
inspiring,
and I'm honest,
uh,
words from our Nobel laureates,
from me,
Xena,
we and all the team on Nobel minds from
the concert hall in Stockholm,
Sweden,
goodbye seasons,
meetings,
and a happy new year.
Okay.